Якби, можливо, визнали Голодомор геноцидом перед війною, можна думати і гіпотезувати,
але можливо, не було б Бучі та Ірпеня.
Я одразу казав, що ця війна надовго і далі боюсь, що ця війна надовго.
Якщо російської опозиції нема, то треба її робити.
А якщо вона є, то з нею треба працювати.
Вступний внесок до розмови це "Чий Крим".
Сьогодні ми у Львові. Спілкуємось з істориком, публічним інтелектуалом,
професором Українського Католицького Університету Ярославом Грицаком. Пане Ярославе, вітаю вас.
Вітаю вас.
Нещодавно Бундестаг Німеччини визнав Голодомор 1932-1933 років геноцидом.
Як Ви вважаєте, чому це сталося саме зараз, якщо врахувати,
що позиція Німеччини ще зовсім недавно була іншою?
Тому що тут їм навели політичну коректність, а зараз є питання політичної ефективності.
Це два різні стани. Не визнавали з різних причин. Тому що в німецькій історичній пам’яті
ключову роль займає Голокост. І це те, навколо чого повністю рухається свідомість
сучасного німецького суспільства.
По-перше, вважалося, що Голодомор може якимось чином протиставити Голокост.
В українців цього наміру не було. По-друге, є сильний образ українців, як антисемітів, нацистів, колабораціоністів.
Є уява, не скажу, що серед всіх, але у певної частини німецької еліти,
є пам’ять, що Голодомор використовувався у нацистській пропаганді.
Ніби це певне відновлення. А третє і, мабуть, головне, тому що Україна перебувала в тіні Росії.
І дуже тяжко було вивести Україну з цієї тіні. Тому якщо в Росії не було геноциду,
то чому проти українців міг бути геноцид. Велося про те, що голод був всесоюзний, а не виключно український -
і тому це вигадка українців. Спочатку націоналістів, тепер нібито українських патріотів.
Я про все це багато писав і багато говорив і навіть незалежно від того,
правда чи неправда, те, що завжди викликало здивування у мене як історика, що в Німеччині немає жодного історика,
який би займався Голодомором професійно. Тобто є певна політична коректність,
і не кожен історик може цю коректність перебороти.
Воно висить в повітрі, але історики займаються різними темами.
Є прекрасне покоління німецьких істориків молодих, які зараз виховалися, які дуже активні.
Але вони займаються іншими темами.
Є прекрасні історики в Італії, є історики у Франції, є у Великобританії, Північній Америці, Канаді.
Немає жодного історика з Голодомору в Німеччині.
І це щось показує. Тобто все це разом показує щось. Німецьке суспільство, німецькі еліти, німці радше
зволікали з прийняттям геноциду. Я не думаю, що вони дізнались щось нове про Голодомор,
що змусило їх прийняти це рішення про геноцид.
Змінилися політичні обставини, а це ще раз показує, що питання Голодомору
було результатом певної політичної кон'юнктури, аніж питанням політичної справедливості.
І в мене це рішення має певний такий гіркувато-солодкий присмак.
Солодкий, тому що це давно хотілося, а гіркуватий, бо таке зволікання нічим не виправдане.
Якщо тепер це питання політичної кон'юнктури, чи можна очікувати, що наступними країнами,
які визнають Голодомор геноцидом будуть інші великі країни Європи?
Звичайно, що можна очікувати. Я просто кажу, що сильно зросли шанси. По-перше, шанси зросли з початком війни.
Тому що те, що робить Путін, виводить повністю України з тіні Росії.
По-друге, дії Путіна, російської армії, зокрема в Бучі та Ірпені мають ознаки геноциду.
Це також впливає. І, по-третє, сам факт, що Німеччина прийняла, це означає, що можуть й інші прийняти.
Ми чітко знаємо, що щодо Іспанії, Казахстану Росія діяла погрозами.
Мовляв, якщо приймете, то матимете негативні наслідки. Тобто це теж політична кон'юнктура.
Оскільки зараз такий фактор зникає. Тобто він є, але в сенсі загрози.
Зараз можна очікувати, що буде нова хвиля визнань Голодомору геноцидом.
А що це означає саме для українського суспільства?
Перш за все, українцям це було більш важливе до війни.
Зараз це вже менш важливо, тому що зараз ми розуміємо, що наше ствердження йде через ЗСУ.
По-перше, нам хотілося, щоби українців бачили, визнали й дивились на них трошки інакше,
ніж просто на антисемітів й нацистів. А дивилися на народ, який зазнав величезні жертви,
але прийшов до незалежності. І це дуже важливо було, нас цього позбавляли.
Крім того, дуже важливо було, що це взагалі питання геноциду.
Концепція геноциду придумалася як певний превентивний захід.
Ми тому називаємо це геноцидом, щоб покарати винуватців і щоб цього більше не сталося.
І на жаль, ми маємо таку ситуацію, що це не діє. У жодному випадку це майже не подіяло.
Скажімо так, у випадку Сербії мало, у випадку африканських країн мало, але,
знаєте, воно не діяло в Європі. Тобто питання дуже важливе.
Прийняття Бундестагом і, я надіюсь, іншими європейськими країнами Голодомору як геноциду
збільшить рівень безпеки: Європи взагалі, а України зокрема.
Тому що геноцид має бути превентивною концепцією.
Я може трохи перебільшую, але якби, може, визнали Голодомор геноцидом перед війною,
можна думати, гіпотезувати, але, можливо, не було б Бучі та Ірпеня.
Покарання винних призвело б до превентивності?
Хоча б символічно. Бо треба показати, що концепція геноциду діє.
Бо концепція геноциду була прийнята у такій формі, що майже неможливо покарати винних у більшості випадків.
За винятком Голокосту. Хоча у випадку Голокосту теж має певну причину, тому що концепція Геноциду має визнати,
що був намір, чіткий намір, а тут щодо наміру є великі суперечки, чи це було дійсно інтенція на початку,
чи радше результатом системи, яка функціонувала і зрештою привела до Голокосту.
Зараз це ніби перейшлося, але я вам кажу, що дискусія щодо Голокосту призвела до розділення у питанні
"Чому Голокост стався?". Навіть у випадку Голокосту це не було цілком так легко.
Тобто були суперечки?
Були суперечки, але юридичного характеру. Але просто та концепція, яку запропонував Лемкін,
вона була набагато ширша. Вона була обкраяна після війни ООН
у зв’язку з тим, як і Радянським Союзом, так і Америкою і Францією, бо вони боялися, що їх попередні дії
також будуть визнані геноцидом.
Чи можливо колись, що Росія визнає Голодомор геноцидом як спадкоємиця СРСР і що для цього має статися?
Я думаю для цього потрібен тиск на Росію.
Російська хвороба зайшла надто далеко, в Росії дуже токсикована історія, причому ця історія є неправильною,
фальсифікованою історією. І я не маю великих надій, що після поразки Путіна це станеться отак (клацає пальцями).
Зрештою як і після поразки німців і Гітлера це забрало досить багато часу.
Я можу думати, що це станеться з часом. Я надіюсь, що це може статися зі зміною одного покоління, можливо.
Але це не означає, що ми маємо чекати, ми маємо щось робити.
Для цього вже зараз ми маємо робити певні кроки, аби змусити Росію, державу,
хоча б певні еліти визнати, що Голодомор був геноцидом.
Це довгий політичний процес?
Якщо дивитися на німецьку історію, бо німецька історія найближча, так. Бо, по суті, це ціле покоління зайняло,
але з чогось треба почати. Я навпаки вважаю, що у випадку Росії чи Казахстану це було б легше,
тому що визнання дій радянського уряду як геноцидного було б іще одним рівнем безпеки для того,
щоби в майбутньому не повторився Путін чи навіть Сталін.
Тобто це могло б захистити і самих росіян?
Так, але для того потрібно, щоб вони це зрозуміли. Навряд чи покоління, яке зараз є, зрозуміє це.
Бо це не є просто історична пам’ять чи історична політика, це є політика, яка має прикладний характер.
Україна багато років добивалася і добивається, аби Голодомор визнавали геноцидом.
Водночас, наприклад, Україна не визнала геноциду вірмен, бо це політичне питання,
і досі не визнала участі українців у Волинській трагедії. Як працювати із цим?
Перш за все чесно, бо я маю цю тезу, яку казав Альбер Камю, мій улюблений публічний інтелектуал:
треба завжди ставати на сторону жертв, якої б національності вони не були.
Тим більше, що ми зараз маємо нормальні стосунки з поляками, поляки є і серед наших українських громадян.
Я весь час це казав, що Волинь має геноцидні ознаки.
Коли я це кажу, я маю на увазі, що відповідні дії поляків мають також характер геноциду.
Але я вважаю, що у тому випадку, головна вина лежить на українцях.
Ми пробували примиряти поляків та українців.
Нам вдалося щодо Львова, але коли ми говорили про Волинь, ми мали повний неуспіх і провал.
І я так бачу з того всього, що ані українці, ані поляки не готові в цьому поколінні зараз
говорити спокійно про Волинь. Я надіюся, що після війни вони будуть більш готові.
Власне, у нашому попередньому березневому інтерв’ю Ви говорили, що ця війна не буде швидкою.
Я одразу казав, що ця війна надовго, і далі боюсь, що ця війна надовго.
Тому зараз з’явився момент, коли її можна швидко скінчити.
Чому я казав, що ця війна надовго, тому що я робив порівняння, що ця війна є конвенційна.
Умовно кажучи, така, як велася Перша і Друга світова війна.
І ця війна більш схожа на першу, ніж на другу, коли сили приблизно рівні, коли великі битви мало що вирішують
і фронт рухається дуже поволі. Але це зараз називається останньою конвенційною і першою технологічною війною.
З прибуттям Хаймарсів, дронів головна битва відбувається саме там.
Битва технологій?
Так. Напевно, хтось скаже, що це остання конвенційна і перша високотехнологічна війна.
Чому я кажу про прискорення - технології входять.
Коли у війну входять технології, війну можна закінчувати швидше.
Я не кажу, що так обов’язково буде, але Україні треба краще скінчити війну протягом наступного року.
Тривають обшуки у церквах, осередках Московського патріархату, УПЦ МП.
Опитування Центру Разумкова показало, що 6% православних України відносять себе до УПЦ МП.
Як Ви вважаєте, чи взагалі можлива повна ліквідація Московського патріархату в Україні?
Я не можу на це відповісти. Тому що вважаю, що це має бути питання слідства і суду.
Це питання має бути повністю розв’язано у правових рамках.
Я не знаю, чи в Україні існує відповідне законодавство, яке дозволить законно ліквідувати церкву.
Тому що церква відділена від держави. Я говорив з людьми, спеціалістами, вони сумніваються,
що можна так просто ліквідувати церкву. Хіба оголосити воєнний стан і робити такі безправові вчинки.
Мені йдеться про щось інше: що мають бути обов’язково покарані ті,
які дійсно спричиняли в той чи інший спосіб допомогу російській агресії. Це очевидно.
Ви говорите про конкретних осіб, а не організацію загалом?
Я говорю про конкретних осіб. Я вважаю, що мають бути покарані особи.
Я вважаю, що більшість тих осіб є у керівництві церкви.
Я думаю, що це не змінить характер цієї церкви. Можливо, це прискорить або відхід від них правовірних,
або сама церква буде мінятися. Ми ж розуміємо, що ця церква є ніщо інше,
як просто ще один державний відділ ФСБ Росії.
Це і проросійськість, і агресія, і пропаганда, також і корупція.
Але я за те, щоб це відбувалося в правових рамках. Максимально. Вважаю, що це тест на зрілість.
Має бути закон. Або закон, який треба прийняти. Поки що законної бази немає. Здається, бо я не експерт.
Що я вважаю, що є і залишається перевагою України, то це те, що Україна не має державної церкви.
Це дуже важливо. Я б не хотів, щоби ліквідація УПЦ МП, якщо вона станеться,
щоб вона не призвела до створення державної церкви.
З того, що лишиться. Бо я б жодній церкві цього не побажав.
Нещодавно у соцмережах були певні не атаки, а швидше певні дописи про те,
що Ви не мали писати для "Медузи" текст про історію України.
Чому я не маю писати, з якої причини?
Я можу говорити тільки про тих, чию позицію я наводжу.
Я не до Вас звертаюся.
Їхня аргументація зазвичай ґрунтується на тому, що це просто російське медіа,
яке працює для російськомовних і тому ви не мали там публікуватися.
Історія з цією публікацією дуже проста і дуже смішна.
У перші тижні війни до мене звернулася "Медуза", аби спростувати аргументи Путіна.
Я це зробив. З цього часу вони не публікували, з’явилися тільки тепер.
Я вже забув про це взагалі. Вони вибачилися, попросили доробити.
Я ж не роблю там російської пропаганди, я роблю там антипутінську пропаганду.
Аргумент ваших опонентів може бути такий, що ніби Вашими словами скористаються проти Вас
і можуть їх використати як елемент пропаганди проти України.
Поки що тими словами користаються проти мене мої хейтери.
Я не бачив жодного російського допису, навпаки там розповідають, що міф Бандери є позитивний.
Яким чином це можна використати у пропаганді - я не знаю.
Нехай собі уявлять чи доведуть, що будь-яке речення з моїх відповідей можна використати як пропаганду.
Вона є дуже антипутінська. Зрештою я писав це як історик, я ж не писав це як пропагандист.
Але ще один аргумент, що ви взагалі мали контакт з російським медіа.
Як на Вашу думку, чи треба говорити з росіянами, чи треба транслювати українські тези?
Вважаю, що так. Говорити треба зі всіма і зокрема там, де є зараз ворог.
Тому що, якщо ми хочемо перемогти, його треба розколювати.
Якщо російської опозиції нема, то треба її робити. А якщо вона є, то з нею треба працювати.
Не з усією, звичайно, деяка з неї безнадійна, але з деякими треба працювати.
Я знаю це як історик, що робилося. Кожна ворожа сторона пробує через голову.
З іншого боку, треба знайти тих, хто буде потенційним союзником.
Українці це мали б пам’ятати з досвіду Першої і Другої світової війни.
Як робилися українські загони, для чого - аби мати на кінець війни майбутній уряд, який буде союзником.
Хто мав би бути у Росії союзником України?
Я чекаю на це. Скажімо так, я знаю осіб, які могли би бути, але вони не мають за собою великої сили.
Ви можете їх назвати?
Я вважаю, що Каспаров говорить цілком нормальною мовою.
Каспаров цілком визнає відповідальність росіян і свою.
Каспаров говорить про вибачення, моральне очищення.
Каспаров говорить про те, що Крим і Донбас є українською територією.
Але за Каспаровим ніхто не стоїть, він просто приємний.
Як називається той лідер росіян, що зараз в тюрмі?
Олексій Навальний.
Навальний має за собою структури, але я досі чекаю, коли він нарешті скаже, що Крим - це не бутерброд.
Навряд він це скаже особливо з тюрми.
Якщо він це не скаже, тоді все, я з ним не працюю.
Вступний внесок до розмови - це "чий Крим". А "Медуза" виразно каже, що Крим є українським.
Багато українців зараз задаються питанням, коли їм святкувати Різдво.
25 грудня чи 6 січня. Що б Ви порадили і як Ви як історик на це питання дивитеся?
Моя відповідь дуже проста. Байдуже коли - лише святкуєте.
А якщо двічі?
А хто вам це забороняє? Якщо це вам подобається двічі, значить ви не дуже сильний в релігії.
Ті, що вимагають чіткого переходу на одну чи другу дату,
переважно сприймають Різдво як комерційне свято і привід святкувати при вогні з вином і таким іншим.
Відбувається те саме, що й на Заході – комерціалізація Різдва.
Але це процес, який відбувається вже давно...
Він почався у 60-ті, 70-ті роки. Різдво комерціалізується, що неминуче прийде і в Україну.
Я не проти 25 грудня. Та будь ласка, святкуйте, але не вимагайте в усіх інших, аби святкували.
Я вважаю, що сила України полягає в тому, аби було і 25, і 6.
Правда в тому, що швидше за все Христос народився у березні або у квітні.
І, може, навіть не в цьому році, а в 3-4 році, про що говорять зараз історики.
Чому 24-25 - тому що це умовна дата. Це дата - найкоротший день року,
яка сформувалася раніше в народів як дата зимових канікул.
Тобто пов’язане з явищами природи?
Так, тому що зима довга, особливо в ті часи, коли знаєте, люди жили не в найкращому матеріальному стані,
коли і взутися, і вдягнутися і їсти не було що. Тому дуже важливо дуже прожити зиму.
Християнська церква цим свідомо скористалась, аби зробити з поганських свят християнські свята.
Про це є велика література, це є дата умовна. Це є дата символічна.
Ти святкуєш народження Христа. А коли він народився - це залежить, до якої церкви ви ходите.
В Україні це не тільки питання, до якої церкви ти ходиш, але і питання політичне
- чи ти святкуєш Різдво одночасно з Росією чи одночасно із Заходом?
Я б не хотів, щоби політика домінувала в релігії.
Але, власне, так і є.
Тоді домінують політики, а не віруючі люди.
Я з дитинства святкував 6 січня, тому для мене цей день завжди глибоко емоційний.
Я старався якось відчувати свято 25-26 грудня, але для мене це не те саме.
Я не хочу, щоб від мене вимагали, аби я святкував разом із ними.
Деякі святкують двічі, я не бачу в цьому нічого поганого. Це тому що мішані сім’ї, тоді це цілком нормально.
Або комусь це просто комфортно. Я не буду нікого засуджувати, тому що треба мати комфорт.
Справа не в даті, справа в Христі. Люди про це забувають.